la fonte des glaciers pourraient être
encore plus rapide est catastrophique
contre prévoyait il y à peine quelques
années
à tel point que d'ici la fin du siècle
des mégalopoles comme new york et
shanghai pourrait être submergé
qu'aucune vingtaine des meilleurs
experts en climatologie au monde
windsor en 2013 des experts du giec
avait produit un rapport choc selon eux
une hausse de 2 degrés de la température
d'ici 2100 causerait une élévation d'un
mètre du niveau des mers à peine six ans
plus tard la barre vient de passer à 5
degrés est à plus de deux mètres
d'élévation
en fait la hausse rapide des
températures crée un effet domino les
glaciers surchauffe et deviennent de
plus en plus fragile et enclin à se
dissoudre rapidement juste pour vous
rappeler il suffit de quelques 3 4
degrés pour passer d'une phase glaciaire
une phase inter glaciaire le groenland
qui s'est construit c'est construire une
période justement beaucoup plus froides
ci disparaît y disparaîtra jamais c'est
comme l'antarctique selon les chercheurs
au rythme actuel 1,8 million de
kilomètres carrés de terres seront
inondées d'ici 2005 et 187 millions de
personnes déplacées
ça peut également signifier des
submersions côtière lorsqu'on a des
tempêtes avec un niveau de la mer plus
élevé bas donc le laurent plus
profondément dans les terres une érosion
plus forte surtout dans les endroits
comme le golfe du saint laurent qui sont
déjà dans certains secteurs très
sensibles à l'érosion
évidemment la possible disparition des
réserves mondiales de glace aurait aussi
des répercussions gigantesques sur la
biodiversité dans les régions polaires
heureusement les modèles de prévision
utilisés pour l'étude évalue cligna que
5 % de probabilités pour que le pire des
scénario se concrétise
du moins pour l'instant ici normand
grondin radio canada montréal